- We've got to say the magic words,
otherwise it's not gonna work.
- [All] Light as a
feather, stiff as a board.
Light as a feather, stiff as a board.
(group laughing)
- Chances are if you've
been to a sleepover,
you've heard ghost stories,
tried to contact the dead,
read fortunes, and attempted
to make your friends levitate.
Bloody Mary, Ouija,
light as a feather stiff
as a board, concentrate,
they're scary and entertaining,
and participating in them
can be a right of passage for children
and maybe even adults.
But do you know the histories behind them?
Do they actually work?
And further more,
why do we love to scare
each other so much?
So join us for one hell
of a slumber party.
(phone ringing)
- [Person On Phone] Hello?
- Hey, do you wanna come to a sleepover?
(dramatic music)
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
The concept of a slumber party
has been around since the 19th century,
when private bedrooms became the norm
and group sleeping became
more fun than function.
The sleepover was solidified
as a social institution
when it was recognized in
newspapers and society journals.
In the early 20th century,
the sleepover turned a bit more spooky.
According to "The Mary Dawson Game Book,"
the slumber party was the
latest and most popular affair
for a young girl.
The book describes the ideal sleepover
as hosted in a bedroom with a fireplace
adding to the atmosphere
to inspire spooky stories
and fortune telling.
The sleepover became a right of passage,
at least for Americans,
by the end of the 1920s.
Particularly for girls and young women.
And they still have that reputation today.
At early sleepovers, communal
fire lights set the scene
for what would become a
fundamental ingredient,
spooky games.
A good ghost story could
win a girl a prize.
Palms would be read and fortunes told.
Driftwood powder would
be thrown on the flames
to produce all the colors of the rainbow.
A bit of science disguised as magic.
- Driftwood, especially
if it's from the ocean,
will burn in different colors.
Mostly shades of blue and light purple,
due to the presence of
absorbed metal salts,
things like copper oxide
and copper sulfate.
When you burn the wood,
you're adding energy to
the atoms in the salts.
They can lose that energy
again by releasing light.
Different elements give
off different colors
just like fireworks,
where the specific mix of ingredients,
many of them metals, create
a whole rainbow of bursts.
But don't try this
driftwood magic at home.
It is literally toxic.
- Levitation games or tricks
have been a pastime for children
for literally hundreds of years.
No, really.
Records from the 17th century
note this curiosity in discussion
of children's folklore,
and the first written
mention of levitation games
appears in "The Diary Of Samuel Pepys."
It details a spell performed
by four French girls
as they lifted a little boy
in a pseudo resurrection.
In the mid 14th century,
a horrific plague, many
today know as the Black Death
swept through the region.
What may have begun as a way for kids
to confront the death that surrounded them
during times of plague
and a mass death endured
as a liminal game.
You probably know what this looks like.
Participants lay only a couple of fingers
on the resurrectee and chant.
In 1843, Sir David Brewster's
letters on natural magic
addressed to Sir Walter Scott
described the ritual with a phrase
that would give rise to a
part of the well known chant.
"To his own surprise
and that of his bearers,
"he rises with the greatest facility,
"as if he were no heavier than a feather."
- I couldn't give her the leverage.
- Yeah.
(Emily laughing)
- Okay, I'm trying not to laugh.
- Nope.
- No.
- In reality, of course,
the person is not suddenly
as light as a feather,
but instead they weigh exactly the same
as what gravity says they do.
When the trick works,
it's simply because the weight of the body
is distributed among four
people, and eight hands,
you're not lifting a 60 kilo
person with your fingers,
you're just lifting 15 kilos,
which is very within reason.
And often, those attempting
the light as a feather ritual,
they try to lift the body
without saying the magic
words, then they fail.
But when the ritual words
are repeated, the lift works.
- [All] Light as a
feather, stiff as a board.
Light as a feather, stiff as a board.
- The words hold no magic
beyond unconsciously
signaling everyone to lift
at precisely the same time.
A spookier version of
counting down three, two, one.
This is an illusion of control,
where our brains assume
a cause and effect link
for two events that simply
just happen close in time.
- And centuries later,
kids are still trying
to levitate their friends with chants.
Why do kids want to scare
each other at parties?
The communal aspect of
these games and rituals
is an important facet.
Not only are participants
bonding when they are pushed
outside of their emotional comfort zones,
they offer opportunities
to demonstrate maturity
by showing courage in the face of fear.
They're a rite of passage,
an event that marks transition or growth.
- Rite comes from the Latin ritus,
meaning religious observance,
ceremony, or behavior.
And the phrase rite of passage,
yeah, much more recent, the
turn of the 20th century.
The same time the
sleepover really took off.
Coincidence?
I don't think so.
The term is generally credited
to French ethnographer
and folklorist, Arnold Van Gennep,
who in 1909 argued that
the ceremonial events
involved a sequence of
three distinct parts.
Separation, transition, and incorporation.
Sleepover games, albeit loosely,
under the hallmarks of this definition.
Separating from the familiar,
both one's home and comfort level.
A transition, the participation
and the spooky test
or celebrated ritual.
And finally, reincorporation
back into one's own home
at the end of the sleepover.
A liminal space is an in between one,
familiar, but not entirely comfortable.
There's a level of discomfort
sleeping in a space that's not your own.
And sleepovers occur first and frequently
during a liminal age, puberty.
Which is terrifying enough
without adding all the scary stories.
And while under adult supervision,
they are peer run environments
that promote activities not
allowed in every day life.
Granting children an
opportunity to explore
their own identities.
Eating marshmallows until you get sick,
staying up way past bedtime,
and summoning ghosts,
yeah, not usually a kid's daily routine.
Sleepovers aren't all about rebellion,
but curiosity, exploration,
and independence.
On the cusp of adulthood,
many children and teens
want to test the boundaries
of what is known, literally
and metaphysically.
One ritualistic practice
that really test boundaries is
communicating with the dead,
or trying to, at least in my experience.
And fun fact, while the slumber
party was gaining popularity
in the 19th century,
so was another social trend, spiritualism.
In 1848, young teen
sisters, Kate and Maggie Fox
developed a cult following
for their reported ability
to communicate with the dead,
via a coded wrapping technique.
They took their act on tour,
demonstrating their abilities
to large paying audiences,
ushering the spiritualist
movement into popular culture.
Participants in the spiritualist movement
believe the soul lived on past death
and tried to seek guidance
from the spirit world
at small group occasions,
often led by an employed medium.
While attempting to
communicate with the deceased
is nothing new in human history,
spiritualism took these practices
out of religious or traditional ceremonies
and into the popular imagination.
Drawing rooms, public
halls, theaters, camps,
and other leisure spaces,
joined believers and skeptics together
to witness communication
into the afterlife.
Objects might levitate,
spirits could leave their
impression on photographic plates,
whisper in the medium's
ear, or tap on a table.
There were certainly true believers
in the spiritualist movement,
but even for the worst skeptical,
the experience itself was important.
That collective fear experience
that offered the possibility
of an inexplicable mysterious event
was too tantalizing to miss.
People who didn't have access to mediums
would engage in other small rituals
attempting to communicate with the dead,
or see into the future.
Cue Bloody Mary.
If you've seen "Monstrum's"
Blood Mary episode,
you already know that in
the early 20th century,
mirror divination rituals were popular,
ramping up during the Halloween season.
Young adults, particularly women,
turned to the mirror
to see into the future,
often with the intention of
identifying their future spouse.
The Bloody Mary variation
is one of the simplest,
as it only requires three things,
a dark room, a mirror, and a chant.
I'm trying not to blink,
and I'm trying to make
eye contact with myself,
so I feel like I'm seeing something here.
- [Alex] Oh, out of the corner...
- Oh, god, the TV.
No!
- You unplugged it.
- That's...
- [Joe] What happened?
- No, it didn't.
- That was an unplugged TV.
- Tools some spiritualist
use to connect to the dead
also made their way into
sleepover tradition,
like the Ouija Board.
In February 1891, Baltimore
inventor, Elijah J. Bond
patented a toy, or game, called Ouija,
or Egyptian Luck Board.
Supposedly, he named
the game on the advice
of his sister-in-law, a medium,
who asked the board what
it wanted to be called.
It spelled Ouija.
Talking boards, simple
boards with printed letters
predate the Ouija, and served
essentially the same purpose,
the communicate with spirits.
However, Bond's intent
wasn't a means of spirit communication.
The patent says that the
player's touch of the hand
is what moves the planchette.
Capitalism.
This was not the only parlor game
marketed to communicate with the dead,
but it would become the most popular.
Ouija really took off in the 20th century,
when it began appearing
in pop culture texts.
In 1920, a book, "Our Unseen Guest,"
followed the story of a married couple
who began to communicate
with a World War I soldier
after they discovered a
Ouija Board on Halloween.
Anonymously published and
marketed as nonfiction,
it contains two letters
dictated by the spirit himself.
In 1990, the authors were revealed
to be two newspaper reporters,
and closet spiritualists.
But it was a 1973 horror
movie that would skyrocket
the Ouija Board's notoriety
and popularity, "The Exorcist."
- Hey, where'd this come from?
- The movie adapts William
Peter Blatty's novel
about a young girl possessed by a demon
after playing with a Ouija Board
she discovers in the basement.
Other pop culture references to Ouija
frequently show the gameplay collectively,
sometimes a game
contributes more to comedy,
like in "Sugar And Spice," or "Friends,"
but more often, it's evoked
to help scare the audience,
like in "Ouija," "Thirteen Ghosts,"
"The Conjuring 2," or "Veronica."
While legends like Bloody
Mary are evoked in ritual,
these are done primarily to insight fear
rather than actually summon a spirit.
A Ouija Board blurs the line
between occult practices
and playful evocation of terror.
Some scholars argue
that publicly vocal fundamentalist
Christians in the 1970s
along with the Satanic Panic of the 1980s
contributed to a shift in perspective
of these so called occult sleepover games.
Both movements attributed
any dabbling in the occult
as inviting in the devil,
associating such practices
with the demonic.
- [Erica] Well, you can actually...
No.
- Oh my god.
- Wait, what?
What was it, you?
- It has to be Joe.
- You're lying.
- It's 100% Joe.
- Your smile, it's definitely you.
- [Joe] 'Cause one of
you is messing with it.
- I'm not doing it.
Whether you believe or not,
it's hard to deny the omnipresent reach
of the Ouija game today,
with the board's familiar lettering
appearing on rugs,
shirts, mints, fake nails,
and throw blankets everywhere.
Nervous to dabble in the spirit world
for answers about the future?
You could always try concentrate.
This trance game in meant
to predict how you will die
and involves a really creepy poem/ritual
designed to give someone the chills.
The origins of this one are very vague,
and no, Dwight did not invent it.
My best guess is it developed
during the mid 20th century
as a messed up form of guided meditation
meant to scare people.
Fun fact, I remember
playing this as a kid,
not at a sleepover, but during
recess at my Catholic school.
Supposedly, the color you
see after being pushed
indicates how you will die in the future.
More than trying to experience
a supernatural event,
these rituals are about
creating connection
with the other participants
and testing boundaries.
Fear can challenge us and traumatize us,
but it can also bond us.
Strange games and liminal spaces
allow us to confront the
unknown in safe environments,
preparing us for the many
unexpected mysteries of life.
Before you go, I wanted to remind you
that a new season
of our sister show, "Fate
& Fabled" is underway.
Join me and Dr. McTier
for an all new series
of the wildest, most adventurous,
and sometimes weirdest stories
from our strange world's
folklore and mythologies,
right here on Storied.
But it was a 1973 horror movie
that would skyrocket the Ouija's Board...
The wigi board.
Luigi board.
So evocation is right?
- Yeah.
- Aw.